so I'm starting today with a warning and
I think this is an important one and
this is a warning to my fellow
dosomething leftists you know Trump
talks about the do-nothing left I care
about the do something left I've always
cared about getting things done and the
warning is as follows do not allow the
right and in particular the trumpian
right to make the next three and a half
months up until the presidential
election about these culture war topics
that they're increasingly trying to use
to distract from the policy failures of
this administration and to distract from
the governance failures of this
administration now I'm including in this
the Trump administration itself trumpets
but also the Republicans who maybe
they're not vocally Pro Trump but
they've stood aside and allowed Donald
Trump to do essentially whatever he
wants they've rubber-stamped the judges
and to really understand this we've got
to do a little bit of homework so first
of all when we talk about culture war
we're talking about cultural conflict
we're not talking about policy battles
right we're talking about a value a
battle over whose values are going to
reign supreme and these are also often
these culture war battles
they're often over issues where there's
more disagreement than on policy so on
policy we see on health care on abortion
the country's nowhere near United but
there is much more support on one side
there's much less division as far as
50/50 division than we've seen in a long
time so I should remind you there's a
lot of right-wingers and even so-called
enlightened centrists who claim the left
is waging a culture war and the right is
just desperate to get a word in edgewise
or something like that that has never
been less true than it is now
the right is fomenting a culture war
specifically because they believe it
will help them win in November because
they can't justify their re elections in
any other way because they've failed so
let's take the abortion example for a
moment for a long time abortion was a
hot-button cultural war issue and
overtime American opinion about abortion
has become more and more on the side of
most
cases abortion should be legal that
makes abortion less of an ideal issue
with which to wage a culture war now
among evangelical conservative circles
and and in religious groups being
against abortion is still a pretty good
way to raise money for your campaign but
abortion has become a less efficient way
to polarize people to your advantage
right now everything we're seeing when
it comes to sports team names
Confederate flags Confederate monuments
protesters being peaceful versus violent
and to what degree is it one or the
other and to what degree do we need to
give police deference these are all
fomenting a culture war which does not
favor the left in this election cycle
even coronavirus has actually become a
cultural war issue specifically when it
comes to masks as a proxy for this
ideology of freedom and liberty and
don't tread on me there's actually a
debate to be had over for example which
statues should come up should come down
and which statues should stay up which
butt names should be cleansed from
history and which should be allowed to
stand reasonable people can disagree
about you know where is the line between
taking down a statue or what constitutes
an offensive sports team name but the
problem is that for the next three and a
half months it is a complete distraction
from policy and which policy platform we
are voting for
nobody gets health care if you're George
Washington's statue stays up but the
robert e lee's statue comes down
reasonable people can disagree but that
doesn't get anybody health care the
washington redskins changing their name
does nothing to improve education in any
way but it allows the right wing to
continue parroting this idea of woek
leftist mobs spreading canceled culture
they are losing like they've never lost
before on policy and governance with the
exception of getting a bunch of judges
confirmed and that also doesn't get
enough attention while we're arguing
about confederate flags now I've played
clip clips for you over the last few
days weeks where Donald Trump has been
asked about
his biggest first-term accomplishments
and his second-term agenda and he can
barely answer those questions that alone
should disqualify Trump from a second
term but that gets less attention when
they can make this about we're fighting
a culture of Marxism which of course
doesn't exist or cancel culture or
whatever they want to talk about now
where this gets difficult is that
corporate media plays into this
corporate media will stage these debates
with people with particularly extreme
positions on these issues person a says
keep every Confederate statue person B
says take down every statue including
George Washington because he owned
slaves and it is wasted time it's wasted
time number one because most people
don't hold such extreme views like most
Americans I think actually would be
pretty reasonable and they'd say well
there's a difference between someone
known for fighting to keep slavery in
this country or else they will leave the
Union versus George Washington is really
known for other things including saying
we need a president not a king etc and
slavery was a sign of the times it
doesn't excuse Lavery but most people
would understand the difference there so
the debates and media are set up with
people with the most extreme views and
it only serves to distract from the
historic failures we've seen from the
current administration on coronavirus on
foreign policy on education on trade on
healthcare etc they win when the
conversation is about flags and statues
because it hides that they've
face-planted on every important issue
for the last three and a half years so
what we need to do is keep the focus on
policy from now until November 3rd
Trump's polling has imploded for three
major reasons his handling of
coronavirus his handling of the economy
in the context of coronavirus relative
to other countries and his insane
reactions his authoritarian reactions to
the George Floyd protests he's failed to
deliver on just about every campaign
promise the United States is a global
laughingstock those are the issues we
should talk about the failures there and
Joe Biden as an alternative and put
aside these cultural issues because they
benefit from the discussion being about
flags and statues rather than about
their policy failures if you love
feeding your intellectual curiosity but
you're always struggling to find the
time check out one of my all-time
favorite apps called blink it's blink
Isleta consume an entire book on your
way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinka stinkiest has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
accom slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video